o el llamar en un estricto censo la
cumbre de las américas porque sería la
cumbre de algunos países de las américas
así que yo creo que esto en sí es un
autogol que se ha anotado el presidente
de bailén por no seguir la costumbre que
se había adoptado desde panamá de
invitar a todos los países de la región
ahora como encarando también si
continuamos creo creo que también que es
importante el hecho que haya habido esta
cumbre en curva porque el resto de los
países sea única aragua y venezuela son
países que firmaron la carta democrática
interamericana y es innegable que han
habido ahí cientos tejes y manejes que
pueden plantearse como una cuestión a
discutir pero en el caso de cuba la
exclusión de cuba del sistema
interamericano pues por razones
totalmente ajenas al tema democrático
porque fue incluso con razones anti
democráticas cuando el montevideo se
excluyó a cuba de la oea por tener un
partido marxista leninista en ni
siquiera era porque no era democrático
sino lo que había pero tenía un partido
una cinta realista del poder y haberse
aliado al eje chino-soviético que para
1962 ni siquiera existía un 9 chino
soviético
ahora cómo impacta esta situación al
continente en materia diplomática y
comercial por ejemplo
los temas importantes que se van a
discutir aquí como es la pandemia como
es el tema de la migración como el tema
de la integración económica el comercio
que usted mencionó que era el objetivo
planteado en la cumbre de miami y que en
1994 y lamentablemente al introducir
este tema de imponer un régimen
internacional
forzado en la administración vaya va a
perder una oportunidad muy importante
para tener una reunión para alto nivel
con todo incluido no está no estaba de
más si uno quiere tener un régimen
especial internacional para los países
democráticos pero eso puede ser como una
reunión especial que se llama la reunión
de democracias liberales en las américas
pero cuando se hable de una cumbre de la
américas lo esperado y sobre todo
después de las declaraciones de un país
tan importante de las américas como este
médico
yo creo corregir el rumbo e invitar a
todos los países